the thing about sky news tonight is we
have a very unstructured way of
approaching the news we reflect in our
coverage the issues that really matter
to people there's much more flexibility
i think it's not a formal traditional
sitting down at the table authorial
question and answer type scenario we've
got insight from our team of specialists
instead of just giving you the story we
actually interrogate it on pic on earth
so that you can hold the politicians to
make the decisions to account the
technological capabilities of how you
can report are changing all the time
comprehensive in-depth and a bit of fun
in reality there are some simple truths
and we're trying to get to the heart of
what those truths are